bienvenue dans les paradise papers une
fuite de documents qui nous plonge dans
les profondeurs obscures de l'évitement
fiscal 1,4 téraoctets d'informations
reçues par le quotidien allemand
süddeutschezeitung et qui vont encore
plus loin que les panama peppers il
s'agit de 13 millions de documents en
provenance des cabinets a fourbi et
hazard city trust et de 19 territoires
opaques de partout sur la planète
fondée en 1890 à pour be est l'un des
plus importants cabinets d'avocats actif
dans les paradis fiscaux un endroit
réservé aux riches
contrairement à mauzac fonseca firme
délinquante au coeur des panamas peppers
a pour be est une compagnie de bonne
réputation qui travaille surtout avec
des multimillionnaires et de grandes
multinationales
elle se spécialise dans la conception de
stratégies complexes légal pour aider
des entreprises et ses riches clients à
réduire leur impôt d'abord a pour but
créer une série de sociétés écrans
enregistrés comme des entités juridiques
mais qui en réalité n'ont pas vraiment
d'actifs ni d'activités suis dans les
profondeurs du système d fiducie et des
structures complexes met à l'abri et
bouge les profits et le patrimoine des
clients vers des paradis fiscaux dans la
plus grande discrétion
ainsi grâce à une poignée de failles
juridiques et au savoir-faire d'albi les
grandes fortunes réduisent au maximum
leur fardeau fiscal
un voyage labyrinthique dans les
profondeurs du système fiscal
international où l'argent revient dans
les poches de millionnaires ou de
grandes entreprises
paradise peppers bienvenue dans les
recoins obscurs de la fiscalité